[Music]
well i'm alex kirford
i'm the founder of the corporate chess
league financial advisor and captain
of team edward jones so the whole
concept
of the corporate chess league was an
opportunity to bring together
companies individuals in a way that
could be competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior to
the pandemic and covet 19 we were able
to gather here
in the chess club meet face to face and
have games on a quarterly basis
it was a lot of fun had a high level of
engagement
and people beginning to be attracted to
that edward jones has been thrilled
to be to help found but also to
participate in the corporate chess
league
and this year actually it's been a
little bit of a change now that we've
gone virtual
our audience has grown we absolutely
love the corporate chess league i can
tell you
my teammates and i we feel like we're
truly a team and we practice
we have regular practices and we take it
seriously it
has really expanded and the engagement
to want to play
even more has happened during this time
so we took
quarterly meetings to now being able to
put on the corporate chess league
once a month here at edward jones we
actually have
people all over north america about 50
000 close to
associates all over north america i have
a really good friend in the phoenix area
who's passionate about chess
it's hard for him to fly out just to
play into a tournament so now that it's
been virtual
he's been participating on the team as
well so in order to capture the essence
of the purpose of the corporate chess
league
we've been able to provide an experience
where
prior to the competition of chess
actually begins
people are able to come into our google
hangouts page
and be able to see and interact with
each other
in a virtual way and then partnering
with chess.com we're able to provide
the the actual uh tournament and and how
the competition begins
and the corporate chess league allows us
as a team a to bond
and we're doing really well as a team
i'm happy to say and b it allows us to
kind of
you know rib each other a little bit and
and it is a little friendly banter which
we love
and all during that time the st louis
chess club is hosting
a youtube channel that has commentary
from
guest speakers grand masters
international masters
commentating on how the games are
actually going that makes for
a lot of fun for people to be able to
see
how their friends how their colleagues
are doing
during a game by having a professional
be able to speak about
the position and and have fun that way
too
i think during this time it is hard
for to have motivation sometimes we can
get
down on things having an outlet where
competition
can still be involved in your life
having an
outlet where you can still have
networking with your colleagues
has really been a key part of the
success
of the corporate chess league it has
been really fun to be able to not only
get to know the people in my
own firm better and share that that
similar passion
but also get to know people from several
different
firms here in in the st louis area
we've continued to have interest in the
corporate chess league both here in the
st
louis area and beyond we're looking
forward to a great season
in 2021 if you or your company
is interested in being a part of the
corporate chess league
you can go to www.stlouischessclub.org
and get more information we'd love to
have you be a part of the competition
you